Beth is with us in North Dakota hi Beth
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi David the pleasure to toxiel you too
what's up I am in meeting of some advice
of course so I have a two thousand
dollar loan out on my car and I just
brought it into the shop and it needs
twenty five hundred dollars worth of
repairs and I have enough money to cover
the repairs and then tackle my loan with
a vengeance and I'm just kind of
wondering if I should not be parents or
if I should get another car what is the
car worth if it were finished Oh
probably less than a thousand dollars
you do not spend $2,500 on one thousand
dollar car okey-dokey I have to get our
vehicle no no you said you have how much
saved I have saved
okay you have a two thousand dollar loan
on the car right correct okay and the
car will sell for $1,000 probably even
with the repairs needed probably I think
it's got some body of work I mean let's
pretend let's pretend that it sells for
$900 and you put your 1,100 with it and
your loan is paid off now you're
debt-free
okay but you don't have a car so let's
keep time with you just keep talking
about so what do you make I made about
2800 a month okay idea family around mom
yes okay are you single a boyfriend but
talk about your social status I'm talk
about your legal arrangement okay
the soap and you live on your own okay
all right and you make twenty eight
hundred and you don't have a car how are
we gonna get you a car how much other
debt do you have about 11,000 and credit
cards and that's it okay and that's not
including my car loan but okay so let's
pretend that you sold your car and you
took out
two thousand dollar loan to go buy
another car this time though it would be
a two thousand dollar car not a one
thousand dollar car right
you're still two thousand dollars in
debt but you've gotten rid of the junk
mmm-hmm junker okay that's probably a
break-even except for we used up here
eleven hundred bucks right hmm I still
probably do that I mean we're not going
into debt maybe a little bit further
here I don't like it
that's one way to do it have you got any
way you could get a car a drive from
your parents or anything for thirty days
while you just worked your butt off and
came up with a little bit of money yes
actually there's yes I have plenty of
people wanting me you know to use their
vehicles and things like that but I'm
just kind of fiercely independent and
just wanted done broke too yes exactly
it is a good time not to be fiercely
independent okay so I I had a guy loaned
me a car when I was broke and I'm about
as fiercely independent as anybody
you'll ever meet you might guess that
right and it really kind of was hard on
me because the car was worse than any
car I've ever owned in my life it was a
1978 Cadillac with 478 thousand miles on
it and literally that's not an
exaggeration the predominant color on
the thing was bondo and the vinyl roof
was torn loose so when you drove it it
filled up with air looked like a
parachute on top of a bondo buggy this
car was worth this car was worth about
$400 but he loaned it to me for a month
and I drove that thing in deep
humiliation for a month
cops were following me around wondering
to know why I was in that neighborhood
with that car I mean it was unbelievably
embarrassing I hated to drive it to the
church parking lot so I parked it a
block away and walked in because that is
horrible I drove that car for ten years
one month mm-hmm that's how it felt
why Athena sigh I do traveling with my
job and I do have like a beater car that
I could drive around to get myself to
back and you know back and forth to work
oh so you have a metal car what's that
you have another car no my dad
has one that I could borrow but I mean
it's like a $700 car I mean you're
driving a thousand dollar car what the
crap does it matter see here's the boy
here's the point this needs to be a
status does not need to be a way of life
with you anymore it needs to be a step
to where this is over sell your car and
pay it off borrow your dad's beater and
save $2,000 in the next two months
because you live on beans and rice rice
and beans and you work three extra jobs
and you can save til you can save $1,000
a month I want you to take six jobs I
want you I don't want you to have a life
at all your poi boyfriend is not going
to see you you are going to be working
and then you will own a car that is
twice as good as the car that you own
two months from today and you'll be
debt-free except your credit cards and
you're on your way that's what I did I
drove that bondo buggy and I saved a
thousand dollars and I bought a thousand
dollar car four months later I bought a
$4,000 car and I drove that $4,000 car
almost a year and then you know I've
never looked back if you drive like no
one else later you can drive like no one
else but you have to break this cycle
you cannot go back to doing things the
way everybody else does them because it
sucks it's gotten you where you are sell
your car drive your dad's beater for two
months to save $2,000 during that two
months you can do it I want you on a
tight budget with the every dollar
budgeting app download it it's free and
I want you to do no life during the two
months you're not allowed to do anything
because all you're doing saving up money
so you can give your dad his precious
beater back and you get your pride back
that's what you're doing it's exactly
what I did I'm not asking you to do
anything I didn't do I drove a car worse
than the one your dad is loaning you I
promise you and it was a blessing and
and the guy that gave it the loaned it
to me for a short period of time was I
was a good friend he's passed away since
and I will always think fondly of him
for blessing me with that piece of crap
because it changed my life I was driving
a Jaguar and but you know had to sell it
two days before it got repo'd and then I
end up driving this bondo buggy but I
had said during that time I'm never
borrowing
again and you know what I Drive now any
thing I want and some people don't like
that and I don't really care that's
where you're headed kiddo you can do
this you call me back if you need some
help because you got a tough two months
ahead of you
but this is what you should do